[Aplausos]
[Música]
siguen las protestas en Brasil para
repudiar los actos de racismo contra el
jugador de fútbol estamos en el centro
de Río de Janeiro aquí han salido a la
calle los líderes de los principales
movimientos negros llama la atención que
haya tan poco público en un país donde
el 56% de la población se ha dado
declara negra y también en la ciudad
donde nació vinicius es por qué es
porque nosotros los negros también somos
perseguidos aquí en Brasil y hasta ahora
la mayoría de los negros están
trabajando
[Música]
español La cosa más grave Es que la
nación española no considere el acto
como grave cuando decimos considerar no
se trata de la narrativa que Es evidente
y sí de la falta de acción la falta de
energía de compromiso y responsabilidad
que de hecho podría proteger la dignidad
la identidad y la humanidad de vinicios
Junior como hombre negro incluso
incompatible con el código penal español
que en el artículo 510 castiga la
práctica del racismo
esta mañana esos mismos líderes de los
movimientos negros han entregado en el
consulado de España en Río de Janeiro
una carta firmada por 150 instituciones
piden que se cumpla la ley fuera de
Brasil donde el racismo es un crimen y
exigen medidas fuertes contra el racismo